bonsoir nicolas dupont aignan merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
est ce que ça nous fit nous a appris
aujourd'hui
on savait peut-être déjà mais que
finalement nous ne sommes pas tous égaux
devant le vaccin bonsoir à vous sanofi
s'est comporté de manière scandaleuse
j'ai regardé les profits de sanofi 2018
sur 34 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
un taux de résultat net de six milliards
8 c'est-à-dire 20%
c'est colossal cela veut dire que cette
entreprise qui fait des profits
exorbitants sur le dos d'ailleurs des
contribuables français à travers leurs
cotisations sociales pour acheter des
médicaments car je vous rappelle que
s'il ya des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
c'est parce qu'on cotise et donc sanofi
aujourd'hui 10 les etats-unis ont mis
trente millions vous devez mettre un peu
mais quelle honte quelle honte
c'est une honte absolue voilà donc ça
prouve aussi qu'on a laissé faire depuis
tant d'années les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques se constituer en
puissance c'est le l'abandon de l'êta
l'abandon de la volonté politique
capitalisme totalement dévoyé et à force
de ne jamais réagir mais ils se
permettent tout voilà alors sanofi a
repris la parole un peu plus tard dans
l'après midi
d'une certaine manière renvoyer la balle
à l'europe
en dix ans on a besoin de partager les
risques pour produire les doses d'un
potentiel vaccin est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que ça soit légitime même si ce
n'est pas politiquement correct les
états unis financent beaucoup l'europe -
donc ils seront servis en premier je me
fais évidemment l'avocate du diable mais
c'est en tout cas l'argument avancé par
le laboratoire
moi j'aimerais que le laboratoire nous
disent combien les etats-unis ont mis
sur la table et je trouve très choquant
de la part des laboratoires qui accumule
autant de profits voilà donc c'est
complètement ahurissant cet argument ne
tient pas un
sans et s'agissant en plus d'une
entreprise française qui bénéficient de
milliards de crédit d'impôt recherche
donc maintenant ça suffit et la vraie
question c'est pourquoi les médicaments
sont produits par des entreprises
privées
on peut s'interroger pourquoi pas
nationalisées s'il le faut maintenant ça
suffit et il est temps d'arrêter avec
ces féodalités privé ces multinationales
qui encore une fois se croient tout
permis moi je respecte la libre
concurrence
mais j'en ai assez que l'on prie la tees
toujours les profits et que l'on rende
publiques les pertes
donc si je comprends bien l'état devrait
encore payer pour que sanofi fassent
encore plus de profits sur le dos des
malades
maintenant ça suffit alors il ya un
autre élément en tout cas c'est une
information de la part des syndicats
sanofi qui toucherait sont le seul ont
eu 110 à 130 millions d'euros de la part
de l'état au titre du crédit impôt
recherche enfin me cice et du crédit
d'impôt compétitivité un allègement
fiscal controversé qui a été mis en
place sous françois hollande ça
donnerait quelques obligations et bien
sûr c'est ce que je vous dis je veux
dire sanofi à des profits exorbitants
sanofi a délocalisé les productions pour
augmenter sa marge et moi j'ai une
proposition que je fais depuis des
années qui est très simple que les les
médicaments remboursés par la sécurité
sociale soit fabriqué en france voilà
effectivement parce qu'on peut pas
demander si extraordinaire avec ses
entreprises
on peut pas demander à ces entreprises
en fait ces entreprises voudraient avoir
les lois du marché avec des crédits
publics
alors maintenant si on paye de
médicaments à partir des cotisations
sociales
on les fabrique en france pardonnez-nous
ya un petit délai effectivement ce qui
rend parfois compliqué la conversation
et leon les relances l'essai de vous
poser les questions nous laisser
répondre en raison de ce délai emmanuel
macron en tout cas lui veut
qu'un éventuel vaccin soit un bien
public
extraits des lois du marché ce que selon
vous c'est un voeu pieux est ce que
c'est un voeu qui peut être réalisable
concrètement c'est l'évidence ce devrait
être naturel maintenant le problème des
manuels mac on sait que c'est lui qui a
laissé les entreprises tout faire c'est
lui qui leur a donné des milliards sans
contrepartie et après ils pleurent sur
la situation
nous nous avons toujours été cohérent à
debout la france j'ai toujours demandé
que quand il ya des crédits publics
il ya une contrepartie voilà donc s'ils
veulent pas de médicaments remboursés
par la sécurité sociale qui les
produisent ont ils volent mais quand
c'est l'état qui paye parce que c'est
nous qui payons quand je dis l'état
c'est nous un c'est les français c'est
quand même normal se soit produit en
france si vous saviez qu'il ya
actuellement 27 milliards de
remboursements de sécurité sociale de
médicaments 27 milliards par an et on a
laissé délocaliser parce que c'est
tellement facile de dire quand on va
produire en inde le taux de marge va
doubler ou tripler
je sais pas si vous réalisez ce qui
représente un taux de marge de 20% pour
une entreprise dans l'industrie lourde
les pme c'est des taux de marges quoi de
2 3% 4%
sanofi ses 20% donc ils l'ont fait
comment on manque aujourd'hui
médicaments dans nos hôpitaux
vous savez que 35 anticancéreux
médicaments anticancéreux principaux ne
sont plus fabriqués en europe donc il
faut absolument relocaliser tant qu'on
ne re localisera pas on sera dépendant
voilà aujourd'hui clairement les états
unis pratiquent un patriotisme forcené
on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec la sphère des
masques je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez également le vaccin que
souhaite présenter clairement les états
unis ne s'en sont pas cachés est ce que
ça vous choque qu'on devrait finalement
faire la même chose en france
mais bien sûr au lieu d'accuser les
autres il faudrait faire la même chose
mais vous savez on a des nuls
ce sont des nuls suis désolé de le dire
dans ces termes mais quand vous pensez
que pour acheter des masques qu'ils
n'ont pas été capables de les acheter
comptant évidemment avec des appels de
des complications des acomptes en chine
ils ont vendu à ce qu'ils leur payait
les masques il ya un moment il faut se
défendre
donc moi je je demande à la france mais
ça fait des années qu'on parle de
patriotisme économique et mais on ne
fait pas d'ailleurs personne ne le sait
mais pendant qu'il ya cette crise du coc
vie 19 l'union européenne a continué à
signer des accords de libre-échange
déloyaux avec le mexique et avec
d'autres d'autres pays donc ça veut dire
que il ya un double langage permanent
c'est à dire que on voit les dégâts
d'une mondialisation inhumaine moi je
suis pas contre les échanges il faut le
juste échange
et on va pas vivre refermer sur soi mais
il faut un juste échange
et donc pendant qu'on se plaint des
dégâts de la mondialisation inhumaine
on continue on continue donc la vraie
question c'est la cohérence
moi je demande en politique ce que je
demande c'est la cohérence
j'essaie d'être cohérent ce que je dis
j'essaye de proposer des choses en
cohérence avec ce que je dis
le problème c'est que ça fait 20 ans
qu'on est gouverné par des des gens qui
en fait disent quelque chose et font
linverse et c'est pourquoi il ya plutôt
comment dire de confiance politique et
les français ne retrouveront la
confiance politique que quand les hommes
politiques diront la vérité avec ses
inconvénients et ses avantages
moi je vais pas vous dire que de
produire en france sera moins cher
peut-être que il faudra faire plus
d'efforts mais au moins on produire en
france et ça fera des emplois et ça fera
de la sécurité dans nos hôpitaux
vous savez que nos hôpitaux manquaient
de tout de blues
tout ça parce que certaines entreprises
font du profit sur le dos de la
collectivité
merci beaucoup à nicolas dupont aignan
président de debout la france d'avoir
réagi en direct sur rt france